les encoches sont complètement
différentes entre le mail 20 et le
macvin pro de l'autre côté en bas sur
maze improvise avant menton qui est plus
grand que sur le mail 20 autre
différence vous avez été une bonne de
balle aujourd'hui je vous montre un
carton regardez-moi ça j'ai reçu un truc
vous allez voir c'est trop fort hyper
cool dans l'autre sens mais devint mais
devint pro vous ai déjà parlé des mets
vins et des mets vins seront alors ce
qu'ils ont été présentés alors une vidéo
avec mon pote guillaume qui étaient
directement sur place ils sont là tous
les deux alors l'idée aujourd'hui je
vous explique aujourd'hui on va ouvrir
ses boîtes on va regarder un petit peu
la différence alors globalement la vue
des jeux vous cache pas que il n'ya pas
de différence flagrante
ça c'est vrai on va les ouvrir on va
regarder un petit peu quelles sont les
différences esthétiques
regardez un peu ce cadre la boîte va
aujourd'hui enfin le boxing vous blesser
quelques jours jeune et est bien l'un
comme l'autre je voudrais donc deux
vidéos une vidéo de test du macbook pro
une vidéo test du mail demain les deux
smartphones vont être assez proche
globalement kirin 980 dans les deux cas
par contre la différence vraiment se
faire au niveau de la photographie on
fera ensuite un petit comparatif entre
les deux voir lequel est le plus
intéressant sur lequel la lépi ce qui
est très intéressant c'est qu'après on
va comparer par rapport aux hommes +6
tekki et là on va regarder aussi par
rapport à l'iphone 10r s'il ya quelque
chose qui choque
il va quand même pas comment lequel
lavalas par rapport à l'iphone 10r le
made by m'avait pas là il ya pas mal de
choses à dire autour s'est produit une
grosse grosse grosse actu en fin d'année
autour de la tech et surtout de la
téléphonie mobile
donc on regarde ça mais pour l'heure
place à l'ouverture
sûrement au niveau de la boîte mail un
bel 20 prend on va pas se mentir je
crois qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup de
différence les produits sont super bien
fait j'aime bien ce côté
très classieux du packaging très sympa
on voit bien la petite patte griffé
triple caméra leica quelques caméras de
chaque côté donc ça c'est cool mais il
devint trop melgven mais que 23 gagner
l'ouverture la petite languette melgven
pro n'exige rien qu en les prenant en
main comme ça on va en voir les
différences pas si vous faites gaffe
tout de suite moi je la vois la
différence vous l'avez en eau de
l'encoche vous avez ici une toute petite
encoche en forme du goût de fond le
médecin est ici une encoche un peu plus
grande pour le mec vins trop forcément
vous avez si un capteur 3d donc
forcément il faudra un peu plus de
classe design extrêmement bien réussi
j'adore ce côté pascal ont bien à
l'image avec plusieurs couleurs à
l'intérieur on à côte un bios vie un peu
plus prononça côté blocs nucléaires très
très très beau alors écrit sur le mec
vin vous avez le le capteur d'empreintes
digitales que vous n'avez pas sur le
même vin trop parce que vous avez un
équivalent du fric saïbi sur le mec vin
vous avez un tout petit haut parleur
intégré au dessus de l'encoche en forme
de goutte
tandis que sur le match d'impro comme
vous avez ici votre encoches les plus
grandes vous avez votre haut parleurs
façon un peu plus standard mais ça
marche très très bien
autres différences esthétiques on voit
c'est que le mec 20 pro est plus fin que
le matin lors si vous en rendez bien
compte que s'ils me rapprochais comme ça
on le voit il est plus fin il dépasse
légèrement en termes de hauteur j'ai
l'impression qu'ils font à peu près la
même taille l'un comme l'autre gêné
comme ça le mail vin est complètement
cachée et si je me mets devant renvoyer
il dépasse légèrement c'est très léger
mais il ya une différence sur le dessus
sur le mail vin vous avez ici prise jack
que vous n'avez pas sur le mail d'un
procès c'est d'être un émetteur
infrarouge vous avez même ici micro en
tout sommet d'imposer votre tiroir carte
sim qui est là depuis le matin vous avez
ici un haut parleur de l'usb type c'est
dans les deux cas sur une vision
latérale c'est la même chose
tandis que de l'autre côté vous avez si
votre tiroir de cartes sim sur le mec 20
maintenant ce qui me pose vachement
question sans avec 20 pro sait où sont
les haut parleurs parce que vous
regardez en dessous il n'ya pas des haut
parleurs vous regardez sur le côté il
n'ya pas des haut parleurs sur le dessus
y'a pas des haut parleurs sur le côté là
le côté y en a pas à l'arrière- ya pas
de haut parleurs à l'avant vous avez
juste ici votre haut parleurs écouteurs
quand vous venez téléphoner mais pas de
haut parleurs ça je suis vraiment
curieux
lors des phases de test ça va être
vraiment quelque chose en tout cas deux
produits qui sont vraiment différents
c'est marrant parce qu'on les voyants
comme ça en termes de dimension en
termes d'esthétique
les produits sont différents et à la
limite je trouve que le made 20
ressemble davantage au one pucistes et
j'ai même voix ne plus assister à côté
en terme de taille
le médecin est un tout petit peu plus
grand c'est très léger bond les caméras
l'arrière ça n'a strictement rien à voir
pense qu'ils très drôle c'est que les
encoches se ressemblent énormément avant
tout ça on fera un test one + 6 tv snake
20,1 prochainement donc rester connecté
vous verrez ça ensuite à l'intérieur de
la boîte
moi je pense que ça va être top plus dur
savez de kif kif on a ici de quoi ouvrir
notre tiroirs de cartes sim
on tire sur le haut on a des petites
coques à l'intérieur ça c'est cool cool
star du guide petite coque transparente
en plastique assez standard et ensuite à
l'intérieur on retrouve notre bloc de
charges ici bob de charge rapide
supercharge autre câble d'alimentation
usb vers usb type c et puis des petits
écouteurs
autre différence et pas des moindres sur
le mec 20 euros vous avez un adaptateur
prise jack usb type c tandis que l'autre
côté vous n'en avez pas forcément vie
vous avez carrément une prise jack
ici sur le smartphone on a quand même
deux smartphones qui se ressemblent
plutôt pas mal aimé qui sont en même
temps relativement différent les
encoches sont complètement différentes
entre le mail vins et de mets et vins
pro l'autre côté forcément ici vous avez
un équivalent de facebook en bas sur le
médecin prouzat 20 menton qui plus grand
que sur le mail 20 il ya quand même une
différence en termes de design là dessus
c'est pas non plus négligeable
autre différence vous avez des bords
incurvés sur le mec 20 pros tels que ce
soit mais devint vous n'avez pas du tout
d'abord incurvé il est aussi une vraie
différence au niveau des écrans ici vous
avez du lcd ici vous avez dû aux led là
on le voit directement la qualité de
l'écran oled est juste hallucinant alors
ça on va le voir lors des phases de test
petit peu tard on dit me rappelle
vraiment les smartphones de samsung s 9
et 9 pouces c'est vraiment très très
très jolie pour moi d'un point de vue
esthétique déjà le médecin promet quand
même une petite claque comme elle devint
alors après effectivement il ya un côté
aussi très sympa avec sommeil 27 petites
encoches mais franchement on le voyant
comme ça dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire au niveau purement
esthétique
en tout cas moi en regardant directement
pas au travers la caméra je peux vous
assurer que sur le mail 20 pro l'écran
on est vraiment une claque au made 20 on
va parler beaucoup plus loin
oui je vous ferai une vidéo dédiée de
comparaison entre ces deux produits
on va vraiment regarder la différence en
termes de photos vidéos par un peu ce
qui différencie celle de model alors
forcément il y en a un qui sera plus
haut de gamme l'autre un peu moins haut
de gamme en tout cas sur le papier de ce
que j'en ai vu puis connaissant les
produits de huawei on a je pense de
smartphones excellent avec un des deux
qui va quand même beaucoup plus loin qui
est vraiment le modèle ultime en tout
cas sur le papier donc on va le voir les
six mois quelques jours le temps de
vraiment me familiariser avec de l'écran
normal les tester et ensuite vous sortir
plein de tests comparatifs pour vous
aider à faire vos choix pour mieux
comprendre
au final la différence vraiment
l'essence même de chaque produit en
attendant l'arrivée de ces tests vous en
parle davantage je vous invite à faire
une seule chose c'est bien évidemment à
vous abonner comme ça - vous saurez tout
quand ils sortiront voilà soyez sages
d'ici là je vous embrasse nous fait de
gros bisous
restez connectés parce que va y avoir
plein de choses qui vont arriver il ya
plein d'autres produits sont ils sont
par là ça arrive tellement le bada ici
que je finis par une vipère tellement il
était donc on fait comme ça merci à vous
et à très bientôt vous en vous
[Musique]